[Musique]
merci à vous rassembler diviser pour
régner présidence il ya vu merci d'avoir
été là
la toile s'est bien amusé ce week end en
regardant emmanuel macron hurler à la
fin de son meeting parisien
une métamorphose pour le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle parodier en
chanteur de métal trop bien le dernier
rappel je pense simplement que quand on
est devant un micro il faut arriver à
poser sa voix sur les paroisses et la
bourre sur la forme avec deux récits de
référence ni patrick bruel ni johnny
hallyday avait perdu l'habitude après
deux ans loin de la vie politique
française
vincent peillon se lance dans la
bataille avec l objectif dit-il de
rassembler autour de son nom comme un
symbole il s'est rendu dans un centre
d'hébergement parisien
je veux rendre hommage à cette france
qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup celle des
bénévoles celle des travailleurs sociaux
c'est le aussi des professeurs des
écoles qui accueillent ces enfants
d'étrangers que madame le pen veut
mettre dehors
bienvenue je suis impatient maintenant
de savoir sur le fond ce qui motive
vincent peillon
je n'ai pas à susciter cette candidature
vous avez pays il faut arrêter de penser
comme s'il y avait des gens qui sont des
marionnettes et d'autres qui sont du
marionnettiste vous demandez à des
informations du canard enchaîné selon
lesquelles vazan dîner avec marisol
touraine maîtrise et des leçons avec
marc riou lui ment et radicalement
fausses car je n'ai comme adversaire que
la droite dure de monsieur fillion et
l'extrême droite le député eduardo rien
si belle et patrick mennucci lui ont
déjà apporté leur soutien anne hidalgo
de son côté regarderai cette candidature
d'un bon oeil j'ai été très très bon
dans son ami
de france 2 et je vois là je le félicite
mais je pense qu'il nous manquait cette
ligne sociale-démocrate et et que
vincent peillon gamme vous avez l'air un
peu nerveux non mais je trouve que c'est
moi les stratégies d'empêchement ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup pour être très
honnête
la question que je vois apparaître entre
manuel valls et vincent peillon c'est
que ce sont finalement les deux frères
du hollandisme qui se disputent
l'héritage
où sont les femmes dans cette primaire
côté y en avait une
c'était marie noëlle lienemann étaient
candidates et qui a renoncé et qui a
renoncé parce qu'elle a eu peur parce
qu'elle a renoncé par sens des
responsabilités christine lagarde est
attendue devant la cour de justice de la
république dans le cadre de la sphère
bernard tapie et les 400 millions
d'euros versés dont litige qui
l'opposait au crédit lyonnais que je
n'ai plus rien à prouver
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai occupé des
plus grands ministères régaliens
si j'agis c'est parce que il me paraît
indispensable de ne jamais baisser les
bras
[Musique]